congratulations guys it's me this is
really dope thank you
is there another for girls you'd rather
go into the jungle what to kick ass no
it was a grave for what's it like for
you being able to switch speeds cuz you
go from some like Jane the version into
annihilation what's that what's that
like must be fun
yeah it is fun it's freeing it's
liberating to go so drastically
different I mean I'm on my fourth year
of Jane and although in Jane you could
do magical realism and I get to play
like in different different characters
and different eras which is very cool it
never goes this it never goes this route
this is like this is a very different
journey for me and it's nice to break it
up and to stretch my way
um doesn't make you think about what
else is up
they're always
I mean I always think about what else is
out there yeah
dunno yeah I would
you think like a what are some of those
thoughts
share them with us like this
a whole idea after we were talking about
the idea of
energies and cells melding
as being the same thing an alien life
and also
I mean all you guys are making it
imagine the conversations
why we're not enough
because he said again immediately
conversation
it's and I imagine the conversation
[Laughter]
I love good
I mean yes we talked about
valuing scientific implications
then we talked about
so you know the ways in which we self
instructor we talked about our human
reactions to the fact that we're
our own mortality and
talked about everything else Elizabeth
you
don't know I had a matter yet no
the first a man that our future we do
you guys obviously saw her speech
at the Women's at the women's March
okay what were your thoughts on that how
does it change
the way maybe you saw her Oh No
she's been a part of our lives in our
journey for
the past two years I mean
um I I feel like I do
be lucky enough to hear her
and intimate spaces
story and so
I see her as so brave
just wrong and
she continues
all the facets of how incredible
she is and she did that from the moment
I met her
but after seeing that I feel like I've
I just continued
didn't in you to garner so much respect
for her
we had that kind of bravery as in
inspiring
and make you say hey can I do more
as someone who has not a rider
because his voice doesn't inspire that
kind of thing
oh I think so
one of the the pleasures
recently is getting to work
Faison to work with her on organized
you know
on behalf of Times
just separately
like so so I feel like
I feel like this reason
period for me in particular has been a
afraid of really doing a lot more than
I've ever
hold on I think I always used
feel like I was able to
to say what I wanted to save
about evil
but my desire for
ideas of what a woman can do our woman
of college
if do to be more expansive and now I
be like I'm I feel like I
actually
figuring out how to howto
put it into action apartment
the movies that I make
and the tweets that I read
seed so sure
certainly natalie is another as a
a person that inspires me but I really
see her
like I'm
right in there with her you know and
my way and always looking for new ways
as if she is his Gina to do anymore